[Música]
una semana más es un placer compartido
escultura en france 24 la excepción por
supuesto son muertes como las de la
directora de fotografía 'la nena'
hatching incomprensible tiroteo en un
set de película que de por sí llevan al
debate de por qué había munición viva en
un rodaje porque en el western ras no
sólo se halló evidencia de plomo sino
hasta 500 balas blancas falsas y reales
que al ensayar gestos alec baldwin se
transformaron en una tragedia personal y
colectiva el actor y también productor
recibió un arma cuyos cartuchos no
verificó el primer asistente de
dirección que alertó a baldwin de un
arma fría o sea sin proyectil real
ignorando que le había entregado la
armadora
y el trabajo de un armero es
esencialmente llevar las armas al
escenario asegurarse de que se cuide la
seguridad de las armas en el set a veces
también implica enseñar a los actores
mostrarles cómo las armas funcionan y en
general se trabaja con otros
departamentos sobre los requisitos de
armas
después del tiroteo de brandon lee en
1993 las cosas mejoraron drásticamente
no puedes tener siquiera una réplica de
un arma o un arma ficticia en el set
ahora sin tener un armero con licencia
trabajó en todo el mundo y veo que estas
reglas estrictas de tener armas de fuego
en los sets no son las mismas en todos
los países he trabajado en eeuu por
supuesto y debo admitir que los
protocolos de seguridad son muy
estrictos y cumplidos
como es sabido en 1993 brandon lee hijo
de bruce lee y falleció de un proyectil
disparado por error para que nueve años
más tarde creyendo un revolver vacío
john erick head sum se matara por
fractura craneal estas pérdidas
cambiaron unos sets que hoy claman
mayores alternativas no sólo a en armas
falsas o de plástico sino también en
condiciones laborales ya que en ras los
camarógrafos llegaron a hacer una huelga
por pago y alojamiento mientras que en
el pasado el asistente había sido
despedido por mal protocolo
ya no hay razón para tener armas
cargadas en set ya sea de fogueo u otras
debería estar completamente prohibido
ahora hay computadoras los disparos en
meros isd aun son todos digitales
probablemente puedas percibir los pero a
quien le importa es un riesgo
innecesario
explicaba una abogada associated press
que el incidente al tener un seguro no
frenaría las filmaciones en nuevo mexico
el dinero influye y con respeto nos
traslada al comentario de dum no el
incomprendido de un de de david lynch
tampoco el de jodorowsky sino el
millonario de denis mina que dio todo
para evitar la llamada obra imposible
hasta lograr segunda parte para 2023
bill no no sólo adapta con éxito a frank
herbert sino que casa la acción real con
los efectos de forma inédita para el
crear el universo que inspiró a star
wars y alguien fue una carta de amor a
la pantalla grande pero a nosotros nos
convierte en afortunados por ver una
raquis no maldito en lo financiero claro
tal vez si le falte mayor contexto que
si tuve el miedo del imperio ante otro
poder los feudos y este fundamentalismo
es mesiánico pero las penurias vividas
80 años por los fremain debido a los
hard con en que explotaron su planeta y
una especia que es combustible y tiene
propiedades es una realidad que es
nuestra de hecho la jugada del imperio
de asignar arrakis a la casa trade es da
vuelta a la profecía paul y hasta los
gusanos pero la especie que alude al
petróleo es como decíamos nuestra
destrucción de los ecosistemas y de la
especie humana una emergencia climática
que atrae junto a la música de hans
zimmer y el elenco encabezado por
timothy chalet metro
tucson mi sistema
y el amor
[Música]
la llegada de louis michel
en el arte de atreverse bill no está
solo david goyer y george friedman
agarraron foundation la saga de isaac
asimov que se creía inabarcable para
convertirla también en la serie de
ficción de ensueño que como ven es la
gran realidad de hace el tivit plast
algunos fans achacan dispersión
incoherencias sobre los robots y el
desarrollo de la psicohistoria pero
claro hablamos igual de mínimo 15 libros
de tres ciclos narrativos que hoy no
sólo son maravilla visual sino el
reflejo de nuestro declive en la tierra
weiss
este retorno a duley a su antecedente
asimov no es casual tienen galaxias
tienen imperios pero el trasfondo son de
crisis de poder y de materias primas que
corro en lo ambiental justo a la
denuncia que ha pintado sobre el muro el
activista mundano a partir de las
cenizas de los incendios que arrasaron
cuatro de los principales biomas de
brasil al grafitero le llevó semana a
recoger estos 200 kilos de cadáver
natural pero soy potencia por décadas de
amazonía destruida negligencia y
agronegocio hay un deseo de
transformación de ahí los grises que
interpelan la empatía y el tributo a las
brigadistas en concreto a un voluntario
presenciado por valeri está con él y
louis gol
[Música]
el centro de san paulo la ciudad más
grande de américa latina es una jungla
de asfalto es aquí donde el artista
mundano pintó mural de 46 metros de
altura con cenizas para homenajear a los
brigadistas que apagan los incendios
forestales en brásil de bach cada vez
más de la tendencia creo que hay una
tendencia cada vez más fuerte del arte a
volverse activista a ser comprometido
con los temas sociales y ambientales de
la actualidad el arte mismo es una
herramienta poderosa para luchar contra
el cambio climático cru con base a
modelos climáticos para finalizar su
lienzo urbano que mide mil metros
cuadrados mundano recorrió más de 10.000
kilómetros recogiendo los restos de
árboles y animales carbonizados
mundano clasificó las cenizas por bioma
y después creó una paleta de grises para
su obra todo un reto para un artista que
siempre usó los colores
con estos residuos que ya no sirven de
los que todo el mundo quiere deshacerse
estoy creando nuevas narrativas es un
gran grito de socorro del medio ambiente
además de la amazonía y el pantanal las
regiones más conocidas
internacionalmente
el artista también visitó el cerrado de
la mata atlántica ambos en peligro de
extinción
el ser humano todo esto está ligado a la
codicia del ser humano y a los incendios
dolosos causados por el ser humano pero
por mucho que los bosques idiomas sean
diferentes y tengan sus peculiaridades
todos ellos se reducen a polvo de la
misma forma y adquieren un pigmento
natural es el carbono carbono su mural
fue inaugurado en vísperas de la cumbre
del clima de glasgow con la intención de
pedir más acción y menos palabras a los
líderes mundiales ante lo que el mundano
define como cola climático
de nuestras compañeras en brasil a una
noticia que nos advirtió mario carboney
desde la capital mexicana y es que en la
demarcación de iztapalapa el dinero
decomisado al crimen organizado adquirió
otro papel el del libro y fomento de la
lectura lo que antes sirvió a la
violencia unos 22 millones de dólares en
bienes ahora representan cinco mil
libros gratuitos a los que en diciembre
seguirá otro reparto en 60 colonias de
bajos recursos los 21 títulos fueron de
autores o antologías nacionales en
festejo a dos siglos de independencia
lo que fue el maserati de un arco se
vuelve 600 libros clases medias bajas
clases bajas populares que leen que
tienen estudios de secundaria de
enseñanza medio es la gran reserva de
lectores de esta ciudad llegar a ellos
es fundamental
esta restitución también marca a francia
venir en una devolución histórica
condenada a ser incompleta estas piezas
en total 26 del reino de abomey y entre
las que destacan un trono y bastones de
danza de guerreros regresan a su lugar
129 años de haber sido saqueadas por
colonialistas galos el pero es que el
gesto tiene triple mirada es un alivio
para las naciones africanas un logro del
gobierno de manuel macrón a la par que
una estrategia para borrar su tensión
con el continente cuando solo el que
brownlee tiene 70 mil de 90 mil obras de
áfrica
mientras que envíen a varios museos han
dicho basta las prohibiciones de las
redes sociales uniéndose a la página
porno only fans en plataformas las venus
paleolíticas y los desnudos de hielo y
móvil ya ni son carne de veto como hace
más de 100 años los algoritmos los
consideran contenido lascivo llevando a
lactando a la junta de turismo de la
capital que espera así un debate sobre
la censura en las artes
[Música]
tras algunas polémicas sirva la música
de remanso o excitación porque ahora nos
vamos con el rapero de su tiempo que es
george razón este octubre los 40 años de
su muerte debido a un cáncer y el
centenario de su nacimiento se alinearon
para alabar al poeta de este y canta
autor de más de 200 temas que hicieron
de el referente de la trova anarquista y
lo cotidiano aún en estas aguas está
amarrado su último barco su gentileza y
su pipa
[Música]
porque
preciso entre aguas viajas siempre la
música de la franco-colombiana edda díaz
que tras un ep experimental y años de
dulzura y contrabajo nos anticipó con
nenita que en mayo tendrá primer disco
para esta letra estáis lo entre albas y
atardeceres y preguntas a su abuela
paterna que la introdujo en la añoranza
de una colombia única con otras
contemplaciones y raíces
así
[Música]
ven y dime qué diferencia hay entre el
crepúsculo era una manera de saber de
preguntar tal vez es no hay principio
tal vez no hay final hay gente que
siempre le apuesta todo a lo nuevo a la
tecnología y otros que siempre están
diciendo era mejor antes y entonces era
una forma de decir bueno y si si
convivimos todos tratamos de solo ser
auténticos con lo que nos gusta de la
tradición y lo que nos gusta de ahora me
inspiré del del ritmo en bullerengue y
poco a poco va procesando hacia la
música electrónica y se ve cómo se puede
hacer una transición y conectar la
tradición con con la con la vanguardia
[Aplausos]
[Música]
el salto que dará edad lo acaba de hacer
la británico irlandés a bangladesh y joe
kraus que con cada pieza de skin
confirma su curiosidad por las personas
y la diversidad migratoria sexual
laboral que la envuelve hay canciones
duras de violencias y suicidios pero
todas tienen la fuerza para retratar lo
vulnerable con lo genuino de la vida y
es algo inusual en la música pop
disfruten del álbum y nos vemos muy
pronto muchas gracias
[Música]
no